[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
la semaine dernière c'était incroyable
il y a eu des retours même ma mère
elle m'a dit elle m'a dit elle
partout
même dans un club d'échelle pour vous
elle vous adore elle vous attend toutes
les semaines tout le monde vous attend
c'est golem explique alors là encore
aujourd'hui on colle à l'actualité avec
ce qui s'est passé encore cette semaine
et vous allez nous expliquer aujourd'hui
les violences scolaires voilà et ça
c'est vrai qu'il y a beaucoup beaucoup
de parents qui nous regardent d'élèves
qui nous regardent et c'est vrai que
c'est devenu la hantise des grands
frères des petits frères des familles
des grands-mères et c'est vrai qu'on
entend de plus en plus parler de choses
incroyables qui se passent à l'école
alors expliquez-nous c'est un peu
d'ailleurs une continuité par rapport à
ce qu'on a dit la semaine dernière parce
que vous allez voir qu'il y a des choses
communes sur la façon dont on s'adresse
aux victimes donc là on est en pleine
rentrée scolaire et bien tu en pleine
rentrée universitaire et vous avez vu
qu'il y a eu plusieurs événements
malheureux malheureux sur le harcèlement
souvent le qui souvent accompagné de
raquettes donc harcèlement raquette et
bizutage c'est les trois éléments clés
de la violence en milieu scolaire donc
moi je pense comme je vous l'ai déjà
dernière fois que quand on connaît bien
les choses on peut les regarder en face
et donc on peut lutter contre et c'est
ça qui est important c'est que ces
émissions servent à faire reculer la
violence scolaire et je pense que quand
on met des mots c'est un peu l'effort
que je fais en vous présentant des
choses toutes simples c'est elle qui
fait tout voilà c'est à dire de dire à
partir de la connaissance que j'ai du
droit de l'expérience que j'ai eu aussi
parce que j'ai fait voter par exemple la
loi vous avez été ministre de l'enfance
puis de l'éducation donc j'ai fait par
exemple les premières actions contre le
racket à l'école avec des campagnes
d'affichage j'ai fait voter la loi de
d'interdiction du bizutage et vous avez
vu que le bizutage recommence voilà on
va en reparler d'ailleurs avec cette
étudiant qui mange une souris vivante on
a vu aussi sur le harcèlement ce qui
s'est passé dans un collège
d'Alfortville et on a vu aussi encore
récemment le suicide d'un jeune qui
s'est fait harceler et ça c'est
inadmissible dans la France
d'aujourd'hui c'est in parce que d'abord
toutes les la réglementation existe
toutes les lois existent donc c'est pas
la peine d'annoncer encore des plans je
ne sais quoi ça existe il suffit juste
de faire appliquer les choses et que
tout le monde soit au courant les
parents les enfants les enseignants les
adultes des établissements scolaires que
tout le monde soit au clair sur de quoi
on parle alors premièrement de quoi on
parle l'école doit être un lieu de
protection et de travail dans la
sérénité c'est tout il doit pas y avoir
un seul enfant qui va à l'école le matin
ou un seul étudiant qui va rentrer
universitaire en ayant la boule au
ventre soit l'université parce qu'il
sait qu'il va subir un bidutage soit à
l'école parce qu'il y a du harcèlement
et qui c'est qui va et qui va subir
cette épreuve c'est tout c'est la règle
fondamentale donc c'est le zéro
tolérance à l'égard de la violence
ensuite pourquoi c'est difficile de
parler des violences en milieu scolaire
pour les victimes pourquoi c'est si
difficile d'abord parce que c'est un
signe de faiblesse c'est dire l'enfant
qui ou l'adolescent qui n'a pas la
capacité de se défendre face à un groupe
de sa classe ou un groupe dans la cour
de récréation même sur des choses
anodines mais qui vont devenir pour lui
rapidement insupportable par exemple un
cas concret que j'ai connu que j'ai eu à
gérer c'est un enfant qui se faisait
chatouiller tous les matins tous les
matins dans sa classe il y avait 10
autres enfants qui venaient le
chatouiller le papouiller le toucher
partout etc puis tout le monde riait
bien évidemment et bien au bout de 15
jours le gamin il était complètement
détruit et quand il dit je vais pas bien
parce que on me chatouille
qu'est-ce que les adultes du robot
chatouilles c'est pas grave c'est pour
jouer etc sauf que celui qui subit ça
tous les matins ça devient dans le
répétitif et une violence insupportable
donc signe de faiblesse et c'est pour ça
que les enfants n'osent pas parler parce
que on va penser que je suis une poule
mouillée etc une victime toute la bêtise
en cours c'est ça et puis cette
deuxièmement c'est la honte d'être
différent parce que souvent l'enfant il
est harcelé dans ce qu'il a différents
il est trop gros on va se moquer de lui
il est trop maigre le handicap la
couleur de cheveux sa situation
familiale tout va y passer pour servir
de prétexte à un groupe d'énergumène
pour lui mettre la pression ensuite et
l'enfant le rêve de tout enfant c'est
d'être intégré au groupe oui et dans un
groupe de maltraitants il y a les
leaders qui vont être des maltraitants
qui vont vite recadrer vite punir il y a
les suiveurs qui vont suivre ceux qui
vont maltraiter parce qu'ils veulent pas
être dans les noms suiveurs c'est à dire
ils veulent pas être dans la côte du
côté des victimes ils veulent du côté
des maltraitants et puis enfin parce
qu'on s'est connu à l'école c'est pareil
pour le bizutage quand il y a un
bizutage en dehors des grandes écoles
mais qui a été organisée parce qu'on a
donné au bizuteurs par exemple le
listing des étudiants la responsabilité
et la complicité et la même on avait
parlé de la réponse à Dieu du rectorat
sur le sur Nicolas là dramatique et
c'est vrai que et souvent il y a plein
de gens qui nous disent ben le chef
d'établissement a dit bah non parce que
c'est pas euh effectivement c'est
périscolaire donc voilà concerne pas
voilà donc ça est-ce que la loi dit ça
non la loi dit que tout ce qui est
organisée grâce au contact dans l'école
ça c'est bien de le dire et bien la
complicité des responsables et des
encadrants du système scolaire est
engagé parce qu'ils sont complices de
d'avoir rien dit dans l'école et de
n'avoir pas arrêté le harcèlement en
dehors de l'école ça c'est effectivement
très important donc qu'est-ce que c'est
que le harcèlement oui c'est des
questions toutes simples mais parfois
mettre des mots sur les choses et ça va
aider aussi ce qui nous écoutent à
lutter à prendre conscience des choses
d'abord c'est une violence répétée si on
vous chatouille une fois c'est pas
harcèlement si vous chatouille 10 fois
ça devient harcèlement parce que ça
devient une souffrance donc une violence
répétée qui peut être verbale c'est une
insulte qui répétait tous les jours
physique donc un contact physique sexuel
parce qu'on vous touche tous les jours
les ni vu ni connus voyons passe dans le
couloir et hop on vous fait un geste ah
ben non j'ai rien fait donc c'est très
difficile à coincer ceux qui font ça et
puis éventuellement avec raquette
deuxièmement envers un élève qui
n'arrive pas à se défendre il faut
savoir que les groupes de de harceleur
repèrent très vite les autres ceux qui
sont en situation de fragilité vous
voyez en situation de souffrance où ça
se passe mal dans leur famille donc ils
sont ils sont mal à l'aise où ils sont
en situation d'échec scolaire donc ils
vont très vite repérer leurs proies ça
c'est très important ensuite les enfants
les adolescents sont vulnérables par
leur allure physique j'ai dit tout à
l'heure le handicap la situation
familiale etc et
au total on estime qu'entre 10 et 20%
des élèves sont concernés donc c'est
beaucoup presque un sur cinq c'est
beaucoup et du côté des harceleurs aussi
et des très jeunes enfants qui sont qui
peuvent aussi être victimes c'est-à-dire
vous avez des enfants qui deviennent
harceleurs parce qu'ils ont été harcelés
ou parce que dans leur famille ils
subissent des violences c'est-à-dire
quand l'enfant est petit je parle pas
des adultes ou là ils ont la
responsabilité de ce qu'ils font mais
quand l'enfant est mineur il faut
absolument regarder si le harceleur
n'est pas aussi une victime de violence
soit dans la famille soit dans la rue
soit dans le quartier etc alors les
sanctions les sanctions parce qu'on
pense que c'est anodin le harcèlement
mais non c'est interdit par la loi les
sanctions sont très lourdes d'abord il y
a les sanctions disciplinaires
c'est-à-dire que un chef d'établissement
doit immédiatement intervenir par un
avertissement un blâme une exclusion
temporaire ou définitive c'est là qu'on
voit la lenteur de ce qui s'est passé
pour Nicolas qui
Ségolène je vais vous dire c'est souvent
l'enfant harcelé qui est obligé de
quitter l'établissement c'est à chaque
fois on a eu que des cas comme ça et bah
c'est pas normal c'est ça un chef
d'établissement à tout pouvoir pour
exclure du jour au lendemain un élève
arceleur en attendant de voir ce qui se
passe le problème qu'il y a c'est que le
l'inverseur il est pas tout seul donc
derrière ses potes vont s'en prendre
l'élève qu'il y a fait sortir donc et
exclure le le harceleur et ça devient
aussi encore plus compliqué pour lui
c'est ça le problème donc c'est ça ils
ont peur et puis souvent les parents ils
se révoltent parce qu'il les parents ne
peuvent pas imaginer que leurs enfants
étaient harceleur et le harceleur que
les parents vont venir faire pression
sur le chef d'établissement
qui dit qu'il a rien fait donc comme on
l'a vu la semaine dernière le harceleur
se pose en victime et comme c'est du
harcèlement souvent oral ou physique il
y a pas de preuve il faut et les témoins
n'osent pas parler donc ça veut dire que
si tout le monde n'est pas au clair et
si le harceleur c'est maintenant qui
peut risquer jusqu'à un an et demi de
prison de un an et demi à 50 prison même
si c'est avec sursis mais de ces prisons
ferme si justement ça se termine par
un suicide moins de 13 ans déjà pour les
sealers à plus de 13 ans mais si il est
mineur il peut faire de la prison et
pour les moins de 13 ans bien évidemment
c'est une mesure éducative et c'est le
juge pour enfants mais ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que ce que les gens de
savent pas c'est que la loi prévoit des
sanctions comme très très lourdes voyez
et si il y a des affichages dans tous
les établissements scolaires en début de
l'année il faut que les jeunes et les
harceleurs se rendent compte de la
gravité que ça n'est pas anodin et je
pense que du coup la violence peut
reculer très très vite si ça chacun est
au clair et si tout le monde regarde en
face la réalité des choses alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que le bizutage le
bizutage c'est une suite de brimades en
général accompagnée de
d'alcool obligatoire imposer aux
nouveaux arrivants dans les grandes
écoles et les universités pour faciliter
et certaines universités pour faciliter
soi-disant l'intégration
et moi je garde toujours en mémoire le
premier bizutage le premier jeune qui
est mort en bizutage et ce qui m'avait
conduit quand j'étais ministre à faire
cette loi donc un jour je vois arriver
deux parents dans mon bureau de ministre
il me demandait à me voir que c'était
vraiment très important donc je les
reçois et ils me disent voilà leur fils
était dans une école de commerce grande
école de commerce à Paris et il est mort
en bizutage parce que d'abord il y a on
les fait boire de force et ensuite il
était resté toute la il l'avait
déshabillé et le bizutage consistait à
rester tout nu dans la neige donc ils
étaient partis en montagne toute la nuit
bien sûr le gamin enfin le jeune est
mort et les parents étaient là devant
moi de façon en disant mais comment ça
se fait quoi et ensuite donc avec tous
les cas que j'ai eu à régler par exemple
il y avait aux Beaux-Arts de Paris à une
époque on déshabillé les élèves on les
peignait en de deux couleurs différentes
en les forcer à se frotter l'un contre
l'autre et ensuite on les mettait dans
un matelas et en balancer le matelas du
troisième étage et il y a eu des morts
et à l'époque c'était la du silence vous
voyez il y a tout le monde a entendu
parler peut-être des arts et métiers
c'est d'ailleurs on avait l'usinage
pendant plusieurs semaines le bizutage
du rêve le visage très violent et là il
y a un élève qui est mort parce qu'on
l'a obligé à ramper dans un tuyau
d'évacuation d'eau et l'élève est mort
et puis récemment ainsi vous souvenez
aussi il y a un jeune qui est mort d'un
bizutable parce que on le faisait nager
dans un lac non éclairé la nuit un œuf
degré et il s'est noyé et donc tout ça
c'est intolérable insupportable et
redisant bien clairement que le bizutage
est interdit et s'il y avait plus de
sanctions plus rapides aussi sur les
chefs d'établissement qui tolèrent ou
qui donnent les listes des élèves etc je
pense que c'est pratique là seraient
éradiquées et quand j'étais en charge de
cette question à chaque rentrée
universitaire dans le dossier des
étudiants je rappelais l'interdiction du
bizutage et les peines encourus
parce que pourquoi ça reprend parce que
à un moment comme quand on ne rappelle
plus les interdits la loi mais la bêtise
vous savez la bêtise et la cruauté et le
virilisme idiot revient plus facilement
que que la sagesse et l'intelligence
malheureusement même chez des jeunes
privilégiés sont quand même dans des
grandes écoles qui sont dans des
universités à une époque il y avait des
bizutages épouvantables en Faculté de
médecine je pense que ça a cessé en
Faculté de médecine une époque c'était
terrible ou dans les prépas vétérinaires
et ce jeune donc ils mangent une souris
vous avez vu vous aurez vivante c'est
abominable mais c'est typique des
bizutages dans notamment dans les
filières vétérinaires les viscères
d'animaux qu'on est obligé de manger etc
que j'avais interdit j'avais pris des
sanctions et d'ailleurs c'était le même
lycée tiers de Marseille c'est quand
même très étonnant et quand vous avez vu
que les visiteurs ont dit non mais il
était volontaire mais non parce que la
loi vous allez voir la licencion sur le
bizutage même si on prétend que le
bijouter volontaire ça n'existe demander
la dernière fois ça n'existe pas c'est à
dire les témoins qui sont inactifs ou
les encadrants qui ont laissé faire sont
considérés comme complices vous voyez
sur ce tableau et la loi réprime le
bizutage même si la personne est
consentante et moi le parquet peut même
s'auto saisir directement ou un ami peut
saisir le parquet etc et même si les
autres disent mais non ils étaient
consentants forcément pour venir à une
soirée intégration ben oui vous vous
déplacez vous y venez mais comme vous
avez peur d'être exclu du groupe ou
d'être qu'on se moque de vous vous dites
c'est pas grave ou vous que vous ne
savez pas ce qui vous attend et à ce
moment-là vous on prétend que vous êtes
consentants mais ça n'est pas du tout le
cas et ça dit le bien autour de vous si
vous avez des jeunes qui sont dans cette
situation
et puis enfin on retrouve des éléments
communs à ce que nous avons dit la
semaine dernière comment parler à une
victime qui se confie je te crois je
suis désolé de ce qui t'arrive pour le
harcèlement ce n'est pas de ta faute je
vais te protéger il te fera plus de mal
tu as bien fait de parler et puis les
mots à éviter bien sûr tu es sûr tu fais
pas les idées mais c'était pour jouer
pourquoi tu as rien dit pourquoi tu as
pas dit non etc et puis on l'a dit vous
l'avez dit Siri de tout à l'heure
comment se protège les auteurs de
harcèlement de raquette et de bizutage
bah ils disent ben non c'était pour
jouer ah bah non on savait pas que ça
lui faisait quelque chose Ah bah non il
a rien dit ou pour le bizutage ah bah
non ça c'est toujours fait ah bah non
c'est facultatif
est-ce qu'il faut bien comprendre aussi
pour la répétition des choses c'est que
souvent ceux qui ont subi les bilitage
les plus violents vont reproduire vont
devenir des bizuteurs violents pourquoi
un bijouter violent devient un bisuteur
violent on pourrait dire ben non ce que
j'ai subi je vais pas le faire subir aux
autres c'est pour se convaincre que
c'était pas grave et d'une certaine
façon c'est pour se reconstruire d'ici
moi je suis capable de faire subir ça
quelqu'un d'autre ça prouve que ce que
j'ai vécu n'était pas si grave que ça
vous voyez dans l'inconscient donc il
faut casser cette répétition et c'est
pareil pour le harcèlement souvent les
harceler quand ils peuvent
deviennent harceleurs parce que c'est
une façon aussi de se préparer par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont parce qu'ils ont
vécu
voilà puis comment l'institution se
protège bon la vue dans le cas du
récent là bah non il a des problèmes par
ailleurs non mais il est fragile non
mais les élèves qui dénoncent en fait
c'est des bons élèves lui c'est un
mauvais élève c'est parce qu'il est
jaloux des bons élèves etc et
l'institution qui n'a pas vu va avoir un
réflexe tout de suite de protection et
de mis elle va minimiser la violence
subie parce que sinon elle a peur qu'on
lui dit les pas vu plus tôt pourquoi
vous n'avez pas parlé plus tôt donc il
vaut mieux dire aux encadrants c'est pas
grave si vous l'avez pas vu plus tôt
vaut mieux le voir maintenant que
continuer à nier et puis bon lorsqu'on a
vu aussi
pour terminer comme la dernière fois les
ravages sur l'enfant c'est les mêmes que
pour les agressions sexuelles qu'on a vu
c'est les maladies les chèques scolaires
la violence l'agressivité les troubles
du comportement les mutilations et
malheureusement dans la rue encore un
cas de avec les suicides donc voilà si
vous voulez c'est un sujet un peu lourd
mais je pense que si on l'aborde ça veut
dire c'est aussi avec la conviction que
ça peut s'arrêter voyez dans certains
pays on a réussi à faire en sorte que ça
s'arrête donc on va pas beaucoup en
France ça continue et si tout le monde
est bien au clair sur ses droits c'est
de voir et ce qu'on encourt je pense que
ça peut ça peut disparaître parce que ou
qui a vécu un bizutage ici compliqué ou
un truc Géraldine qui nous avait raconté
moi j'estime avoir été harcelé quand
j'étais quand j'étais adolescent ouais
tout durant toute ma période collège
tu veux manger seul à la cantine on me
traitait de péder tous les jours parce
que j'essayais plutôt d'avoir des
copines que des copains j'avais du mal à
en avoir donc ça m'a oui ça m'a tueront
toute mon évolution ça a été compliqué
ouais ouais parce que en fait ça ça nous
suit toute la vie c'est à dire que ce
qui se passe pendant deux trois années
de collège on pourrait dire bah ça il
s'est terminé au lycée ça va mieux tu
grandis tu te fais des copains enfin oui
certes mais ça nous suit parce que c'est
ce qui nous forge on essaie un instant
crucial l'adolescence l'enfant c'est le
moment où on se on se construit on
apprend à se connaître on apprend assez
mais on apprend à parfois à ne pas
s'aimer enfin et voilà et donc moi je
pense que ça ça rendu mon parcours de
vie plus compliqué voilà
quelque chose de très important dans le
mécanisme du harcèlement c'est
l'isolement le groupe va isoler l'élève
harcelé et donc et donc il y a une
double violence et non seulement sur les
faits subis mais en plus parce que le
harcelé va être exclu du groupe j'ai
très fréquent heureusement j'en suis pas
sorti traumatisé mais quand on en parle
comme ça je me souviens que moi j'avais
été harcelé sexuellement par mon
proviseur quand j'étais en cinquième il
faisait je me souviens parce que c'est
des flashs comme ça il fait toujours
venir dans son bureau en demandant mes
montres ta cicatrice d'appendicite tu
mets toujours me que je baisse mon
pantalon etc je refusé etc et à tel
point qu'à la fin il m'a fait redoubler
pour Jaurès dans sous sa coupe
il a dit mes parents Jean-Michel n'est
pas si mur pour passer en 4e il est trop
il est encore trop haut bébé dans son
dans son âme et du coup j'ai redoublé ma
cinquième à cause de à cause de la foule
c'est incroyable il existe encore
j'en ai pas été traumatisé mais c'est
vrai quand j'y pense ça me revient quand
même bien sûr
et bah c'est bien d'en parler comme vous
le faites et d'en parler en public vous
allez voir ça va vous libérer et si
parce que sinon ça expulse des
souffrances intérieures et le fait le
seul fait d'en parler c'est un début de
guérison pas de question si vous avez
des questions c'est juste un contre-pied
justement parce que vous demandez qui a
été harcelé moi je pense que quand
j'étais plus jeune CM2 5e 6e je pense
que je faisais partie des harceleurs
c'est un contre-pied en fait
sous l'excuse de la vanne quand on est
cinq six potes on va vanner le mec qui
est différent et on le charge à la récré
on le charge on le van on le met de côté
en cours on lui fait des coups de crasse
des coups de c'était pas le mot c'est
plus grossier toute la journée on s'en
rend pas compte parce que c'est sous la
c'est sous le chariage et je pense qu'il
y a plein d'enfants de 10 ans 12 ans
pour faire rire le copain on va on va on
va faire une surenchère de Vannes sur le
même mec toute la journée toute l'année
et ça il faut dire au môme faut pas le
faire en fait ne faites pas parce que
sur une vanne vous allez briser un gars
en fait et aujourd'hui disent qu'ils ont
été harcelés moi je pense pas que
j'étais harcelé mais avec le recul je
pense qu'on était cinq six potes 10
potes au collège au lycée j'ai pété
beaucoup plus loin je pense qu'on a
harcelé non je pense qu'avec le recul je
pense que j'ai dû harceler des gardes
c'est bien cette prise de conscience et
il faut dire aux jeunes ne fait pas
parce que pour une vanne pour une vanne
on fait des dégâts derrière ça fait
beaucoup de dégâts derrière mais
derrière ce serait ça serait intéressant
qu'il y a des témoignages vous voyez
dans les classes de collège primaires
des gens qui viennent parler expliquer
ce qui se passe pour que les enfants
réalisent juste pour faire rire en fait
merci pardon merci Ségolène merci
[Applaudissements]